[Music]
tuesday edition pft
ot the post pft live show where we talk
about the things we either didn't get to
or that we want to talk about some more
and chris we have some updated
information i had said that the nfl has
a habit
of not immediately responding to certain
topics that
they would maybe prefer not responding
to but i did press them on this question
of the mini bubble that the saints have
set up for training camp where
sean payton has all of the players and
the coaches and
some of the key staff people staying in
a hotel peter king talked about it
earlier today
the sense was that sean payton didn't
say thou shalt do it
but he did it the team's doing it the
gm's doing it
the leaders are doing it the rookies
welcome it because they don't have
houses yet
so everybody else is just going to do it
and the league's position is
it's not mandatory so it's not
prohibited so
here's the obvious follow why don't you
just have this non-mandatory
bubble this non-mandatory hotel stay
all regular season long that's going to
be the best way to minimize
the virus so you don't need to go to the
union and have
a detailed negotiation on what it takes
to get
clearance to get guys to stay away from
their families
all five months of the season you just
do it yeah
and everybody's just gonna do it and hey
wait
sorry honey i i go everybody else is
doing it i got to do it i can't be the
only one who doesn't do it
and that's it it sounds like the saints
have tripped over the answer to the
question
now the question is whether other teams
will consider doing it for training camp
and then consider doing it beyond
training yeah well i mean
and the saints are interesting too
because they have unbelievable veteran
leadership
we know that they're a team that is like
on a mission right now because they feel
like they probably should have been in
the last three super bowls at least or
you know in some nfc championship games
and whatever else
so you know they're willing to do
whatever they got to do it sounds like
to make sure this
this season goes off the way they
envision it and they're not going to you
know
take the chances to let one of their
players get infected or other media or
other
members of the organization or whatever
it may be could be interesting to see
where this does go throughout the nfl
you're right mike i mean it really is
now i don't know you know again you
can't force
players but i think like in this case
yeah oh hey drew brees is standing there
oh hey cam jordan's there
wait michael thomas is staying there oh
okay
wait i'm you know okay i'm the 47th guy
on the roster yeah
all right if they're doing it i'll do it
too now where does it go mike
can they find a fine line can they find
a way just as we thought about this
and i didn't get to say this when we
were on the show today but because it
kind of came about in my brain after the
fact
and but like can the nfl maybe find a
way or teams find a way to go
okay you're in the bubble right from
tuesday night
till you know sunday after the game then
you get to maybe go home
after the game sunday you know be with
your family on monday hopefully you're
being careful and doing all the proper
things
you know come tuesday morning which is
usually a player's day off
you got to come in get tested blah blah
blah we go through all that
and then we'd like you to check back
into the hotel third tuesday night and
stay there again until
game time after the game or game time
sunday i mean just something that
bounced in my head that
maybe players can get their heads around
and actually maybe want to do something
like that
here's the problem though until they
have point-of-care tests i know
when you come back that you're not
positive right away and don't have to
wait 24 hours for the answer
you're still going to have that doughnut
hole look i look at it this way
what happens every year except this year
in april may and june voluntary workouts
and how many players show up for the
voluntary workouts on the good teams
on the successful teams how many are
there they're all there yeah that's the
thing
they're all doing it you do it and think
of it this way too
do you want to be the one who's going
home every night
and coming back to the facility every
day when all the rest of the team
goes to the hotel and comes back so
you're going to be the one who's got the
cooties yeah remember that when you're a
kid
you're going to be the one that they're
all looking at differently because you
may be the one who's bringing the
virus into the building they're going to
stay more than six feet away from you
you're going to feel different you're
going to feel weird and
when you balance out all the stressors
of
staying away from your family versus
being the one guy
who isn't staying at the hotel you're
going to stay at the hotel yeah it's
human nature
so i i just think that what the saints
are doing here
if they're thin for all we know this is
just kind of the trial run
and if it works we're gonna carry it
into the season
and this is the way that sean payton is
using the rules of his advantage
it's not mandatory you don't what do you
mean it's not mandatory you don't have
to do it
we got a room for you if you want to
sleep here sleep here
if not go home that's fine if you want
to do it
go ahead go home everybody else is here
you want to be the one who goes home
go home that i'm telling you that the
team
that does that is going to be the team
that's more likely to keep the virus out
of the building yeah and the team that
keeps the virus out of the building
is the team that's going to be standing
there when we get to january
and playing those single elimination
games that count the most mike this is
why it is again
it brings me back to the you know
something i keep saying and again i'm
not trying to be insensitive here
i know this is real but this is to me
where you know
i i think if a team misses a week
because of coba 19 it should count as a
loss
this is these are the scenarios because
what if you have a team like the saints
who's doing everything right and doing
it by the book
nobody's sick you know and then what
they have to miss a game or two because
the other team gets coveted 19
and oh i don't know maybe they'll make
it up or whatever else and it's going to
you know ruin their schedule and the way
they're playing because why
the other team was unprofessional and
didn't do things right i just think it's
an interesting thing but either way
mike i think you're right that the
saints are going to lead some teams
down the tunnel to have this
conversation and
you know again the the the scenario i
brought up too with the 24 are we still
at 24 hours even for these nfls guys
i mean that's just crazy like i told you
i got tested it was six hours
i just don't understand understand that
at some point but
you know i think if they could find a
quicker way to get the results back you
might be able to pull off hey go home
for two days then back to the bubble
uh you know if not everybody's
comfortable just going to a bubble for
for five months in a row let's remember
this chris
thousands of americans who are getting
tested not because
it's part of their screening when they
show up for work every day but because
they think they may have it
they have to wait five seven days or
longer because of the demands right now
for the testing right
there's that the nfl has avoided so far
this ethical question of whether or not
they're hogging the reagents
even though they have their own setup
their own national lab that is
flying these test uh samples
to be properly evaluated and you get the
result back within 24 hours
they have avoided this question of
whether or not all of the resources
they're using
for those tests the reagents to
determine whether or not you have it
are taking away from the general public
uh you know the reality is
efforts to push it even more
aggressively will put even more of a
strain all right
well you're more of a disparity the
government seems to care about it you
know then i can't worry about it i can't
you know i know i'm just saying that's
if they don't care here's the thing
point-of-care testing is coming yeah
it's not accurate enough yet though
the concern is it's in the 80 to 85
percent range accurate that test you got
if they didn't send it off to be tested
in a lab
that test may not be as accurate as it
could have been as accurate as a test is
that they send off
for full analysis uh at a laboratory so
it they hope that they get point-of-care
testing we all need
to have more rapid testing we all need
to have more available testing but i
think a lot of these problems are solved
if you do have point of care testing but
but
this notion and you know to your point
that if a team is wiped out of a
position group
and the commissioner just says okay well
we'll postpone this game
until you know week 18 or maybe we won't
play it at all
you're right that could be manipulated
like oh this is the week we're supposed
to play the chiefs hey commissioner
we don't have any offensive lineman this
week we can't play the chiefs this week
i mean
you know uh and and when you're talking
about
legacies and employment yeah and
everything that rides on the outcome of
these games there's going to be a
temptation if you think there's a way to
avoid playing the ravens or the chiefs
you're going to explore whether or not
there's a way to fudge these results so
you don't have to play the ravens of the
chiefs
yeah well and it can become a
competitive disadvantage just from the
scenario you brought up to like oh
okay now we reschedule a game for week
18. well that team was supposed to
you know not be playing it was a their
bye week or something like that
to get ready for the playoffs now you're
making them play a game because they did
everything right and
you know team b didn't do anything right
back in october
and now you know team b's not in the
playoffs and has nothing to play for in
this last game but team a
needs to now win this game because they
need their seating in their playoffs to
be the right spot and
that's to me where it becomes a little
bit of an unfair competitive advantage
and i just think that
yeah you're going to have some teams who
are going to have the veteran leadership
and the coaches and everything like that
like a sean payton or a belichick who we
know are going to do
everything right and i just i don't know
if i feel the same way about every team
across the board that way and
you know to me that's unfair to the
teams that are doing it the right way
well and and uh i think as we get closer
and closer to the games that count
we're going to start to hear more
stories like this and and i think that
some of these teams are going to just
make a de facto bubble
and they're not going to ask for
permission they're not going to tell
anybody they're doing it it's just going
to happen organically and naturally
and those are the teams they're going to
be in the best position you gave me a
time out on that one
you know that i've never seen you do
that one i did i didn't i i just
i know i didn't i was trying to i was
trying to get you
off the topic before you went to i know
i just never stopped
the rabbit hole yeah all right cool
[Music]
you're gonna give me a timeout during
this one because i know you have no
interest in the xfl but
but chris a lot of people do and now
that the rock
has purchased the xfl along with his
ex-wife
and business manager danny garcia and
redbird capital
they got it for 15 million i was stunned
yesterday how do you buy the xfl for 15
million here's how you buy it for 15
million
there were no other qualified bidders
for the xfl which tells you
what it's worth right now i mean a
sports league and a pandemic when we
have no idea when you can sell tickets
for people to come watch your games
we have no idea whether or not espn abc
and fox will want to continue to
televise those games
especially if you try to play in the
spring and there are sports that have
been moved
from the fall of the spring like maybe
college football uh it's not going to be
the most lucrative property
but they have a vision for it they
believe in the product
it may take a few years for it to get
back to what it was starting to be
they had some decent tv ratings they
started to drop off they were facing
some stiff competition
march madness was coming before the the
real march madness arrived
in the form of the pandemic but i'm
telling you
you get there aren't a lot of people
whose names you can attach to something
like the xf valve i agree
and have instant excitement and there
aren't many that are going to trump
vince mcmahon
and r the rock is one of the ones that
takes this to another level and it gets
me even more interested and chris you
were completely
disinterested you got to admit when you
heard the rock was getting involved you
at least had a little bit of a flicker
it opened my eyes there's no doubt yeah
i mean because just about everything the
guy touches you know turns to gold
i mean he sees what he's the most uh is
the richest
movie star in the world right now i
think per movie or per year whatever it
is either way he's raking it in
very smart we know he's got a football
background you know he is the kind of
name or figurehead
that could maybe sway a young kid or
whatever else to
to think about oh xfl maybe one day if
they can get in a spot
can challenge the nfl or steal a player
or two or whatever it may be but that's
where it's gotta get to
so he's gonna have to work on
publicizing the league
getting it to be getting to a place
where yeah everybody takes it serious
and wants to do it
but i still think hey the big obstacle
is gonna be always come down to what we
said to begin with
you know it's we just when you need some
stars
and that's where dwayne johnson the rock
is gonna have to start thinking about
how he's gonna get those guys on his
team
you know i know there's there's plenty
of guys out there to build teams and
certainly some solid football players
that aren't in the nfl that probably
deserve to be
and you'll get some good quality
football but we like to watch stars in
this country
we do that's that's that's what it's all
about and we want to see guys that can
do special things
and that's where to me will be the
biggest hurdle
into legitimizing it and really you know
turning the corner to where somebody
like the guys like me
will want to watch it yeah and that's
the key they need to attract stars they
need to cultivate stars they need to
keep their stars that was one of the
issues that i had
and they were starting to right the
quarterback for the houston roughnecks
whose name i've already forgotten do you
remember who it was well i can't
remember who it was
but he was playing really well he's the
guy that was interested
for a cup of coffee you're talking about
the carolina panthers walker
walker pj walker yeah jay walker yeah
he's he's been well i didn't pay
attention i couldn't remember what team
he was on so when you said houston
roughnecks it did nothing for me i just
if i was going to get there when you
said he was the best quarterback for
sure yes
but but they need star players they need
star power
and until they have star players the
star power comes from
the rock so look i'm i'm interested in
it there are people out there who want
more football there are people out there
who want more things to bet on
and i think as we see more and more
states legalize sports wagering to
rebuild their budgets post pandemic
it's going to be weed and wagering those
are the two ways to rebuild your state
budgets
people are going to want things to bet
on and i think they're going to be like
one of the two
uh the xfl oh i know you do uh we'll try
to get you to like the other one as well
uh maybe we can we can't bet on the nfl
per nbc policy but since we don't cover
the xfl we can bet on the experts i
don't want a wager and have that stress
on
i can't do it either i i don't i have no
desire to do it i have
no desire to do it zero well you're like
because for me you can get emotionally
invested without money on the line
and here's the other thing too when and
knock on
formica or whatever this is the uh i
mean we both
we both are doing okay financially right
right for me i'm not going to get a rush
out of winning 50 bucks
betting on i'm not going to care right
who cares and i'm never going to wager
anything of real value i'm not going to
put real money 500.
would you get a rush of the 500 no i
wouldn't i and here's the thing
it would torment me to lose the 500 i
know it would much more than it would
make me feel good to win the 500
because what i'll think about is all the
crap i could have bought with the 500
that i just lost all those bottles in
1942 you can't buy them anymore you know
yeah all three of them thank you for
introducing me to the most expensive
tequila
on the market you bastard yes
that much i bought you got me a bottle
of it for christmas right
i ordered a second bottle because i
can't find it around here i got that
much left
and i'm saving it for like a special
occasion because i know once it's gone
i'm gonna either have to plunk down
another 150 bucks
or go out on a wild goose chase trying
to find it at a liquor store around here
so thank you very much
all right one one last thing before we
go rashad bateman
the big ten receiver of the year for
2019 from university of minnesota has
opted out
of the college season he's done chris so
he's the second big name to do it he's a
first round prospect in some mock drafts
but who the hell knows
based upon you know the absence of that
last season and we see how names
go up and down with that last season
this is in advance of the big ten not
announcing what they're going to do
there's still a chance the big ten is
going to shut it down
right chris they seem to be the most
responsible of the power five
conferences recognizing
where this is going and it's not going
anywhere good and rashad bateman's
saying
i'm getting off i'm not going to be part
of this experiment i'm not going to be
your guinea pig here
i'm out and i think more guys are going
to be following suit i wouldn't be
shocked i mean it just i
you know again we're concerned about the
nfl i haven't heard anything to make me
give me any optimism as far as college
football and how they're going to pull
it off
so and those amount of kids and and of
course it is kids
and yes i'm sorry but you can't trust
kids the same way you can trust a 31 nfl
31 year old nfl football player so yeah
i i i i would
i would not be shocked to see more and
more guys you know fall off and
yeah you know between him up in
minnesota we had the virginia tech
corner right he was a first-round
prospect as well
you know um yeah they're they're not
sure about the year they're going to
protect their interest and i know the
virginia tech kid had
some family issues too so it was it was
a risk and he didn't want to take it and
i understand that
you know especially when you're not
hearing a concrete plan or any plan
as of right now to how it's going to
work caleb farley the virginia tech
quarterback wrote wrote a few paragraphs
that were in football morning in america
and when you drill down to some of the
things he was saying it's horrifying
yeah a hundred guys in an area and
nobody's wearing masks and guys went on
vacation and they come back and they're
at myrtle beach and they're here and
there and
um you know the the problem with the
college football programs there is no
uniformity
the ncaa isn't doing anything to require
rules and regulations for testing and
other protocols
how is that i just the ncaa just
is rules rules galore for the players
rules galore dion sanders can't pay five
cents for dez bryant's lunch
but damn well we're not gonna we don't
know we don't care about rules we just
gotta figure out how we're gonna get our
money this year
that's all it's all about and they piss
me off the ncaa with their crap
yeah no one is protecting these kids
that's why we applaud what the pac-12
did the group of players who
posted at the players tribune.com their
reasons
for making demands and their demands and
uh
if they're not allowed to have
representation via a union
if the ncaa isn't going to protect them
then they need to stand up and they need
to protect
themselves and they ultimately need to
vote with their feet
like caleb farley has done and like
uh the uh minnesota receiver rashad
bateman has done and i think more will
be doing
the same uh especially if they continue
on this track now
one last thing the ncaa board of
governors will meet on tuesday
they may and all they can control is the
championships
right the bcs the final four bcs
final four yeah the the conference
championships
they can delay or cancel those but that
won't stop the colleges from playing
within the conferences if they choose to
do it so we'll see what happens
we're getting you know it's august 4th
for crying out loud and there's no
clarity yeah
no real clarity about what college
football is going to do which tells me
they don't know what the hell they're
going to do three of the conferences say
that they plan to play but i
i just i i know that it's a lot of money
to walk away from especially when you
don't have to pay the players
but i i it's unless you've got
the kind of of protocols the nfl has put
in place chris
it's irresponsible to put your players
at risk and to put the community at risk
because even if the players don't get
sick you become a super spreader
with all those players potentially
taking the virus out to the community
and endangering the vulnerable members
of the community and i know the
people out there that just want the
world to go on unaffected by this say
well just
just just isolate the vulnerable you
know it's
it's imp it's imp uh what what do you do
you put them in it you put it you put
them literally in a bubble what do you
do to the people who are vulnerable and
there are people who are vulnerable that
don't know they're vulnerable right
exactly a lot of people have diabetes
and they don't know they have diabetes
what a way to find out you got diabetes
because you had died from covet 19. yeah
no
i i know you're right and these are all
things uh that to worry about
there was a time where i really thought
with college football only the small
rich schools like the notre dame's and
the usc's
with the small enrollments and they got
a lot of money and maybe they would be
able to pull it off but
you know i just i don't know i'm very
pessimistic about college football and
then let me just bring back the one
thing
did you say vote with their feet you
know i i i
did you say that because i don't even
know what that means i just wanted to
explain that means leave
that means walk out you vote with your
feet bye bye
big brain all right i figured it out i
gotta i'm gonna vote i'm gonna vote with
my feet i'm done you're we're done great
stuff uh we were only gonna do a few
minutes today and it took about 20. but
there's
you know that's the thing the two hours
that we're on the air
stuff still happens and it's good to
have this extra little show to
kind of catch some of it and talk about
it chris great stuff as always we will
be covering everything as it happens
fyi i have the full letter agreement
from the nfl and the nfl pa which is
both a blessing and a curse because now
i got to read it and figure it out but
i'll be posting about the details all
day long at profootballtalk.com
and we may have some of it to talk about
tomorrow morning can't wait
shut up i can't even remember casey matt
casey
shut up copy paste copy paste snarky
comment
see you tomorrow on pro football talk
bye
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports